avec nous ce matin trois députés en
studio pour en parler
le conservateur jean marc deltell qui
est au hac et au centre réal fortin et
les bloquistes et les néo-démocrates
avec s'envoler seul bon dimanche à vous
trois messieurs je voudrais je vais
commencer avec vous le gouvernement
parlait de main tendue ce qu'on a senti
cette main tendue de discours de jeudi
je pense que oui tout le monde attendait
de voir si elle va avoir un ton qui
était conciliant si on voulait
travailler avec les autres partis
politiques je pense que le message
commun était bien passé là dessus à vous
savez un discours du trône
une tentative de séduction surtout dans
un cadre de gouvernement minoritaire
on a vu que certaines priorités du npd
ont été évoqués mais pour l'instant nous
on trouve que la glace est un peu mince
que ça manque de détails pour des choses
qui sont complètement absentes de ce
discours du trône là mais on prend ça
comme base de discussion puis de
dialogue pour les semaines à venir je
détale vous chef a clairement entendu il
y en avait pas suffisamment là dedans
soyons quand même bon joueur on est bien
heureux de voir que le gouvernement
s'est engagé à baisser les impôts de
bien des canadiens pour la loi
semble-t-il évidemment de tête de diable
se trouve dans les détails on va voir de
quoi il en retourne pas ce que vaut être
prudent par rapport à ça mais c'est
quelque chose de mal avec lesquelles on
est d'accord bien entendu sur baisser
les impôts maintenant il ya bien des
choses qui sont pas strictement rien sur
l'unité nationale nous on estime que
c'est l'élément majeur du prochain
gouvernement ce propos bien que c'est la
vice première ministre clip de ça il
strictement rien sur l'international et
bien des flancs aussi de l'économie qui
ont été mis de côté en tant que la
question de l'énergie canton ainsi que
deux cent mille canadiens qui ont perdu
leur emploi au cours des quatre
dernières années
il faut prendre ce dossier à bras le
corps est juste une petite phrase tu es
tout mince à travers un discours du
trône au dessus c'est inquiétant c'est
décevant voyez venir à ça parce que oui
on en a parlé quand même de l'économie
monsieur fortin vous clairement votre
chef à trouver qui en avait suffisamment
là dedans parce que rapidement après le
bloc a dit noël appuyer ce discours
balle suffisamment non évidemment que il
ya plus que selon je suis d'accord parce
que mes collègues m'ont dit le c'est un
peu vague finition exactement alors nous
passons condition d'appuyer on est en
campagne on n'est pas ici pour faire
fonctionner gouvernement pour nous non
plus ici pour poser des entraves
on est ici pour le québec pour les
québécois et on a trouvé dans ce
discours du trône n'a absolument rien
qui nous empêche qui vient nuire à notre
à notre programme aux engagements qu'on
a pris vis-à-vis de nos électeurs
au contraire de l'ouverture comme on
mentionnait ouvrables et entre autres
sur la question d'aider nos aînés alors
nous on est on essaie de stress une base
de départ une base de travail et on va
travailler là-dessus avec eux mais moi
je suis un peu surpris de la
précipitation du bloc québécois depuis
si rapidement le discours du trône
sachant que parmi tout le discours le
mot québec n'apparaît même pas une fois
les priorités du gouvernement du québec
ne sont pas là pour beaucoup de
québécois l'environnement est au coeur
des préoccupations
et on ne parle plus du tout des moments
qui renonce oui mais on ne parle pas du
tout d'éliminer les subventions aux
compagnies pétrolières et gazières est
une promesse de 2015 pilote tout d'être
koussa de disparus on parle de
carbonates pour 2050 mais on parle pas
des cibles de 2030 qu'on va rater puis
qu'on devrait être encore plus ambitieux
c'est facile fait des promesses pour
dans 30 ans mais je déteste premier
ministre du québec avait formulé cette
demande précise concernant entre autres
la laïcité ne pas attaquer la laïcité
concernant plusieurs pas dit que
l'attaqué était sorti avec ne se
retrouve pas dans le discours inaugural
qui est appuyée par le bloc québécois ça
nous surprend parce qu'il savait dit que
j'allais être la voix de l'assemblée
nationale la chambre des communes
premier ministre fait cette demande
02 management oui on accueille suivre
mais c'est la première chose qu'on
t'offre on en discute sont entre autres
qu'il ne pourrait me prend de faire la
promotion des débats rose qui est bien
qu'on aurait aimé soeur mais vous savez
la litra ce n'est pas le discours du
trône n'est pas n'est pas un
un exposé exhaustif de ce que l'on a
frôlé ne fera pas et ça veut pas dire
qu'on va toujours d'accord avec le
gouverneur au contraire il ya de bonnes
chances qu'on soit fréquemment en
désaccord avec le gouvernement
ce qu'on disait qu'on veut faire un
exercice intelligent on veut pas
s'opposer pour s'opposer
peu importe que dedans et comme on parle
d'un exposé de deux grandes lignes et
que y'a rien dans ses grandes lignes qui
vient heurter notre mission qu'on sait
qu'on s'est donné que les électeurs nous
ont confié ici à ottawa on me dit ça va
on va travailler avec s'objectera pas
pour le plaisir de ceux de s'objecter on
n'est pas ici pour le bloc ou pour les
conservateurs les libéraux le npd on est
ici pour les québécois pour les
québécois on parlait des grandes lignes
vous parliez tout à l'heure
pas de mention a pas de mention de
l'ouest de l'unité nationale mais en
même temps ce que ce pas un peu normal
justement parce que un discours du trône
c'est une ébauche sont des grandes
lignes ce que penser que ça va arriver
plus tard ben oui mais justement aussi
le discours du trône le sait le festival
de la tarte aux pommes le tout tout le
monde doit être d'accord avec ça il ya
des éléments fondamentaux là dedans le
premier ministre confié à la numéro 2 de
son gouvernement le dossier de dollars
notre point de vue c'est notre priorité
nous les conservateurs les relations
intergouvernementales l'unité nationale
et à parler dans discours de
l'importance de développer des
ressources naturelles par exemple une
phrase sur convient déjà 20 minutes de
temps et de façon très exhaustive et
expéditive au point où les amis du bloc
ont été heureux de débat comme on parle
pas de pétrole brut pour ça un seul pour
les 50000 québécois qui travaillent là
qu'est ce que ça aurait pris là dedans
qu'est ce qui vous manque et je commence
avec vous moi je pense que une des
priorités que nous on s'est fixé ou un
pdc le respect des droits des premières
nations il ya 20 ans n'en parlait des
premières nations et partant malgré la
pression faut que les bottines suivent
les babines participer après dit oui
mais on aurait pu dire tout de suite on
redonnait un exemple concret on va
arrêter la contestation judiciaire des
compensations pour les enfants des
pensionnats puis des réserves
autochtones hip hop du to mention de ce
soit ça fait des semaines que le npd
nous on le demande
ça aurait pris une phrase puis roddick
concrètement voici comment qu'on va agir
pour les premières nations il en parle
pas qu'est ce qui vous manque à nouveau
vous ai parlé d'unité nationale
concrètement le ciel est un élément qui
avait fait pencher la balance pour vous
sur l'été quoi bagnols secteur de
l'énergie qui souffrent énormément au
canada comme vous êtes 200000 emplois
perdus ya rien là dessus pour justement
redire
redynamiser cet élément là et je vous le
rappelle ses cinquante mille québécois
qui travaillent dans cette industrie là
et que ces gens là méritent le respect
monsieur fortin vous avez dit que vous
alliez les pieds mais ce qu'il y avait
quelque chose que vous auriez aimé
entendre précisément ben écoute et
encore une fois je pense que c'est des
grandes lignes mais c'est certain que
quand n où l'on naît on aurait aimé
entendre un signe du moment clair à
l'effet que on sest investir dans le
pétrole
mon ami joueurs soient pas contents mais
c'est ce qu'on souhaitait cma plan
québécois qui sont latents vous dès
qu'on vous dit que le gouvernement
fédéral 16 de ma passion de la pétrole
et investissent davantage pour
développer des énergies vertes
l'industrie hydroélectrique au québec le
manger dans ma circonscription aux
autobus lyon le qui vend des autobus
californie comment se fait que tous les
autobus scolaires sont pas électrique
il ya plein de choses sur lesquelles on
pourrait investir développer de
nouvelles technologies des batteries
plus performantes on avait souhaité sûr
mais on comprend que c'est pendant 10
rounds secours de tourner que ça va se
faire
puis on complète le québec idéal c'est
pas ici au togo qu'on va le définir
c'est au québec
alors nous on a encore une fournée le
pauvre on regarde sur le pied là dedans
qui nous empêchent de travailler dans le
sens de secours ont cédé leur langage
mais n'empêche pas l'autre on avait des
éléments de notre programme électoral
là-dessus justement pour permettre le
développement de la transition
énergétique de rien comme ça non plus
mais c'est pas en insultant les 50000
québécois de travail dans cette
industrie là qu'on va faire avancer les
choses et en oubliant les selles demande
du premier ministre je suis un ancien
travailleur d'industries pétrochimiques
et je suis loin d'avoir envie d insulter
monsieur détachement scopont voudrais
pas très haut on parle j'ai envie de
vous attendre parce que tout le monde
sait qu'en pelles à jeudi en sortant est
bonne on l'appuie nous on veut discuter
non la plupart mais dans les faits on
faisait les vraies affaires
orton pas en campagne les y'a personne
d'entre vous qui ont envie de partir en
campagne de même atteint hier
qu'est-ce que vous êtes aux électeurs
qu'ils disent et a perdu 4 politique
dans toute cette espèce de prise de
position la hollandaise je commence avec
vous monsieur maurice je pense que c'est
pas c'est plus que du théâtre c'est des
négociations des négociations parce que
nous ce qu'on a dit depuis aujourd'hui
que jack c'est quand la dernière fois
qu'on va négocier sur un discours du
trône je sais pas si simple que ça un an
mais on est dans une situation
gouvernement minoritaire alors les
symboles sont importants les messages
politiques sont importants et jack
nicklaus souffre dit nous on n'est pas
là pour faire fonctionner le parlement
on est là pour faire fonctionner le
parlement pour les gens
si ça donne des résultats concrets ça
aille de la vie des travailleurs des
travailleurs et des familles on est là
pour les partenaires de bonne foi on est
prêtes à être constructif c'est message
qu'on envoie aux libéraux mais là on est
habitué avec les libéraux des très beaux
discours hop et après ça assez peu
d'action c'est pour ça qu'on a une
certaine méfiance du côté du bénévolat
vous êtes aux électeurs oui nous on
serait prête à défaire ce gouvernement
là demain matin si besoin et si on pense
que c'est pas correct ce qu'ils ont mis
sur la table on a quand même déposé un
amendement au discours de notre chef par
rapport à la proposition qui a été faite
puisque va tester ses soutiens au poids
c'est ta maman là mais fondamentalement
faut quand même pas oublier que nous
avons tous dûment été élu avec un mandat
précis qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
convergent nos idées parfois oui mais
parfois non qui on doit représenter ces
gens là non sans rappeler que justement
le gouvernement et les coûts pour le
parti que le plus de votes aux dernières
élections c'est nous maintenant on qu'on
accepte la réalité parlementaires des
faits mais le gouvernement doit prendre
acte du fait que devant lui il ya quatre
parties avec les vaincus qui sont pas du
même monde et jeté au sol et verquin dès
jeudi qui s'appuie à la fois discours du
trône la saison et dévoué vous vous êtes
quoi monsieur forte à ce qu'ils disent
votre chef avait déjà envoyé le signal
assez clair qui était prête à travailler
avec le gouvernement il l'a dit à sa
sortie de la rencontre avec monsieur
trudeau est ce que ça va être ça la
marque de commerce du bloc locaux des
prochains on voit on va régulièrement 0
on est d'accord avec les libéraux
notre marque de commerce ou risque de me
répéter la wii de servir le québec
alors encore une fois ne comptait pas
objecté pour seul objectif appuyer pour
et puis on va travailler et je souhaite
que ce parlement ne fonctionne je pense
qu un parlement divisé nos minoritaires
ses facettes qui peut arriver de mieux à
l'ensemble du canada et au québec
alors j'en suis j'en suis membre de ce
parlement compte un bon alexandre nous
parle de négociations je suis d'accord
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir négocier se
parler et ce sera dans l'intérêt de tous
à quel point est-ce que vous avez les
pressages commence avec vous ce deltell
avait l'impression que le message des
électeurs qui est envoyé à monsieur
trudeau en stagnant minoritaires
travailler avec vous avec vos amis
est-ce que ça s'adresse à vous aussi
avez vous l'impression que ce message là
et comment ça se traduit dans votre mot
extérieur exactement ce que j'avais tapé
tressois tour d'élection c'est le
message que tous les politiciens les 338
reçoivent c'est à dire
à veiller ensemble oui fine entendu le
savez travailler ensemble en fonction de
nous priver de nos demandes et qu'on a
reçu comment soit pas se mettre une mini
jupe pour avoir youpi youpi tout le
monde est content soit l'école des fans
la chambre des communes
on est là pour travailler en fonction du
mandat qu'on reçoit
mais oui on veut très dur est évoqué
plusieurs projets de lois sont adoptées
à l'unanimité aussi après les débats qui
ont cours
il faut que nos points de vue soient
exposées mais oui des éléments qu'on
compte va écouter une autre le npd un
creux parti de gauche un parti
progressiste si le gouvernement libéral
veut aller dans cette direction là puis
amener du progrès social puis aider les
jeunes les plus démunis les travailleurs
et travailleuses
on va être là pour eux pour leur livrer
des résultats je suis un monsieur fortin
exactement même chose je suis content
d'entendre ça effectivement un
gouvernement qui dirige avec un petit
peu de un petit peu de gauche un petit
peu droite un petit coup de sang du
nationaliste du qui donne la marge de
manoeuvre nécessaire au québec où
s'épanouir tout ça ça peut être mangé on
verra je vais vous entendre dernière
question vous avez parlé de parti
progressiste on a beaucoup parlé de ce
discours du trône à cette semaine comme
d'un discours du trône progressiste avez
vous l'impression que vous êtes un peu
mis de côté du côté conservateur
disons que oui mais c'est clair mais à
partir du moment où le premier ministre
a été dûment élu on comprend que ce
discours et sa politique au
conservatoire et il ya quand même que je
vous ai dit que la phrase qui porte sur
les baisses d'impôts on va voir de quoi
il en détaille avec quoi il en retourne
mais le fait d'avoir complètement mis de
côté le secteur énergétique 200000 15
euros perdu leur job devoir me côté
d'une tk ne vienne nous nous préoccupons
entre ce discours là va être adopté
clairement on verra pour la suite des
choses jean nadeau des votes de
confiance que ça revienne réal fortin
gérard des texans boulerice merci
beaucoup